I would like to take this moment to
thank president Charles vest and his
wife mrs. Rebecca vest for hosting this
event I would also like to welcome MIT
alum dr. Julianne Malveaux and class of
80 it is a pleasure to have you here
this morning
furthermore I would like to thank all
the members of the Martin Luther King
jr. planning committee to whom we owe
this wonderful morning when I call your
names please stand up professor Jerome
Friedman professor Richard Milner
Reverend John West neck assistant
professor Katherine Drennen assistant
professor Larry Anderson associate dean
Arnold Henderson junior assistant
director Deborah Lieberman professor
John diamond Shaw Associate Director
Robert sales Co director Paul Pavano
Toby whiner
student administrator in the political
science department special assistant to
the president dr. Clarence G Williams ex
officio Chancellor l Phillip clay ex
officio and committee co-chairs Dean Leo
Osgood jr. and professor Michael Feld
thank you all for contributing to the
success of this event
we will now begin the program with the
invocation from Reverend John West Nick
following the invocation the MIT gospel
choir will present a musical selection
we will then have breakfast after
breakfast we will have two students mr.
Nicholas Pearce class of 2007 and mr.
Bruce Webster a graduate student guide
us in a reflection on the life and
legacy of dr. King Chancellor Philip
clay will recognize the 2003-2004 Martin
Luther King junior Leadership Award ease
we will then have a musical selection
from mr. Ronald Hopkins then we'll hear
remarks from dr. Charles and Bess and he
will introduce our keynote speaker dr.
Julianne Malveaux following the keynote
speaker
Provost Robert Brown will recognize our
Martin Luther King jr. visiting
professors for the 2003-2004
academic year let us now begin the
program with the invocation by Reverend
John West neck right after Reverend West
necks invocation we will begin breakfast
Reverend West Egg
please join me in prayer Almighty God we
gather this morning in celebration as a
lizzing living testimony to dr. Martin
Luther King jr. one of the true heroes
in our recent history we lift up his
values in life his leadership and
struggle his dreams and his memory help
us here to leave behind the hindrances
and annoyances of the morning thus far
so that we might be present in full
awareness of the day the people around
our table the faces and our friends in
the room enable us to enjoy the speakers
and the music but not without hearing
the full meaning of what they have to
say to us the implications for each we
know we have not completed the task of
justice nor of peace help us all to do
our part in bringing the dream into
focus for our nation in the world
enliven us all we lift up also the
leaders and followers old and new who
continue to labor for a better reality
lift up all those who have made this
morning possible bless the food before
us all those who prepared it and those
who will serve oh god we lift all this
up to you amen
I would now like to present that the MIT
Gospel Choir
[Music]
for everyone to see
there's no other place I'd rather be
[Music]
me
everyone to see
[Music]
there's no other place
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
and Bruce Webster a graduate student and
Aeronautics and Astronautics they will
guide us in a reflection on the life and
legacy of dr. King we will hear first
from Nicholas Pearce Nicholas
[Applause]
good morning ladies and gentlemen
I'm Nicholas Pearce a freshman in the
Department of Chemical Engineering on
this morning when we have gathered to
celebrate the life and legacy of one of
our nation's most prolific civil rights
leaders we must also take care to
consider the progress that our nation
has made since dr. Martin Luther King
jr. articulated his dream in August 1963
and those 17 brief minutes a little over
40 years ago Reverend King brought the
struggle for civil rights by black
Americans to the national forefront
King's words on the steps of the Lincoln
Memorial that day declared his dream for
a free America for all people we
remember the dream but does the heart of
the dream still beat today we would be
careless to believe that dr. King's
dream is dead in any sense however it is
more than fair to say that his dream has
not yet been fulfilled dr. King's dream
is in the hearts of millions of people
many of whom were not even alive at the
time of his speech the fight of dr. King
and his co-workers in the vineyard of
civil rights was a valiant one and it
continues today though the fight for
civil rights continues the battle
against them rages with a double
determination the onslaught of enemies
of socioeconomically driven civil rights
is unwavering showing no signs of
subsiding while socio-economic civil
rights were the focus of dr. King's work
they are not the only issue that has
been championed because of his efforts
other groups including homosexuals women
senior citizens and the disabled have
benefited from federal legislation such
as the senior citizens freedom to Work
Act of 2000 the Americans with
Disabilities Act of 1990
those both address issues of civil
rights however affirmative action has
not been addressed since 1964 with title
6 of the Civil Rights Act without
question the principal issue of these
times is affirmative action especially
in higher education among all of the
issues of civil rights it seems as
though affirmative action has received
the least legislative assistance
arguably because it helps the
disenfranchised the very people who dr.
King aimed to assist here at MIT
opponents of affirmative action have
risen up to confront the minority
focused project interface and meit's
programs the latter of which I am an
alumnus there are those who have
committed themselves to the systematic
underachievement
of minority students especially
african-americans programs such as the
two I previously mentioned decidedly
shattered the underachieving stereotype
these programs and other inclusive
initiatives supported by the Institute
have come under tremendous fire my
positive experiences from the meit's
program led me to apply to MIT from my
undergraduate education meit's made the
richness of the MIT experience available
to me for one summer it gave me a quick
snapshot of the dreams that I could
pursue the Institute is to be commended
for its earnest defense of these
programs however the national spotlight
was thrust upon the University of
Michigan in its affirmative action
admissions policies in two Supreme Court
cases our very own president vest sig
last year's breakfast as an opportunity
to announce MIT support of the
University of Michigan and its policies
mit has a rededicated
to diversity initiatives in the face of
legal opposition MIT has made prudent
decisions regarding its stance on this
issue and must continue its efforts in
the face of pressure
we cannot be discouraged because backing
down due to pressure simply allows the
civil rights advancements of the past 50
years to dissipate into nothing a state
from which had been successfully raised
we must be careful not to forget to look
back as we move forward drawing
inspiration and courage from the
tenacity of men and women such as dr.
King in this 21st century civil rights
are indubitably under siege the attacks
are great the opponents many but the
resolve of the principled American has
not faded one bit there is erosion
across the landscape everything is being
challenged or contested even the things
that were once considered automatic
voting rights challenged the right to an
equal educational opportunity challenged
in essence the right to have your rights
is being challenged the concept of civil
rights being under siege is a definite
reality ladies and gentlemen the fact of
the matter is this race still matters in
America we cannot be so naive as to
believe that the opponents of civil
rights have taken a break despite the
rhetoric being tossed around that we
live in a free and equal America the
writing on the walls of time suggests
otherwise those who suggest that our
society is a colorblind one or incorrect
though most Americans may not be
blatantly racist
the proverbial playing field is not
level for everybody in American
institution
clearly dr. King hoped people would not
be judged by the color of their skin but
by the content of their character the
dream yet lives the hope is kept alive
but until the day that every member of
every race color religion or Creed is
afforded the same chance to excel in
this nation and in our world civil
rights will remain under siege we must
not let the efforts for the past 40
years he lude our eternal grass as I
conclude the words of dr. King come to
mind let us be dissatisfied until those
who live on the outskirts of hope are
brought into the metropolis of daily
security he went on to proclaim that me
we must walk on in the days ahead with
an audacious faith in the future until
our faith has become substance the fight
for civil rights must continue and
arrest assured as long as there is a
fight there will surely be an opponent
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much Nicholas we will now
hear from Bruce Webster
good morning ladies and gentlemen
Maurice Webster descended from a people
recognized by the United States
government as the Navajo Nation
we call ourselves Dannette in our
tradition I am of the NACA Dannette and
clan and born for the US Christian clan
I am also a graduate student in the
Aeronautics and Astronautics department
here at MIT the United States Air Force
veteran and an alumnus of the Nike
sports and fitness machine in Beaverton
Oregon this morning I would like to
speak about whether it is rhetoric or
reality are our civil rights under siege
looking at the two United States Supreme
Court decisions of 2003 it is a reality
that the civil rights of all are in
received what appears to be under debate
in the application of the 13th 14th and
15th amendments to the Constitution of
the United States the petitioner is
incredible versus Bollinger and Greta
or Gatsby Bollinger contend that they
were treated unfairly in their
applications submitted to the University
of Michigan a distinction must be made
what is fair can be unjust but what is
just cannot be unfair judge Clarence
Thomas offered a dissenting opinion in
Grutter vague vulgar comments were made
contending that a man should be should
not be assisted that a man should be
allowed to stand on his own the
dissenting the dissenting opinions
offered rebut the belief that diversity
enhances the education of all a
ridiculous argument is made to allow
applicants
feet shorter or 20 years younger special
consideration on their application these
opinions argue that the emission system
is fair since it was devised by the
dominant Society
this is the same dominant society that
enslaved men based on race this is the
same dominant society that decided who
could vote based on race based on
literacy and based on gender the
application system is based on
standardized tests there are courses
available to study for all standardized
tests and of course these courses are
offered in most large cities for a
substantial fee a fee that cannot be
paid by some because they are not in the
upper class what is fair and what is
just in the United States it is said
that you can be whatever you want to be
in this capitalist society it is said
that you earn your way to the top or as
one ad put it we make our money the
old-fashioned way we earn it
apparently they chose to overlook where
the wealth in this land was acquired
wealth acquired on the backs of slaves
wealth acquired on deceitful deals made
with the people that did not understand
wealth acquired on the subsidies
provided by the poor and wealth acquired
with SAT LSAT and GRE scores that can be
bought where is our wealth to be
acquired when we are allowed to come to
the table 200 years after the wealth
this land has been divided and handed
out that is the truth that the dominant
society does not want to talk about
Farren just is not pretty when the
magnifying glass is turned on the
dominant society I've heard all my life
about the tragedy of the Holocaust that
occurred in Nazi Germany what about the
American Holocaust what about the
attempts made to exterminate my people
what about the policies of termination
by relocation what about the stealing of
our children by adoption and what about
the sterilization of our women Nazi
Germany had Hitler the United States
government had Kit Carson the United
States cavalry and the Bureau of Indian
Affairs now we have a whole generation
of boarding school survivors these
children were taken from their homes
from their parents to learn the ways of
the dominant society these children my
parents my aunt's and my uncles were
taken from their homeland their hair was
cut and they were not allowed to speak
their native language and they were not
allowed to practice any of their
traditions how would you feel if you or
your children were taken by a foreign
nation at five years of age that same
language that was beaten out of my
parents is now being celebrated as an
integral part of the United States
victory over Japan in World War two does
that sound just it sure doesn't sound
fair
that is the America I know as the
America I fought for most of my
traditions I've come to learn as an
adult but my language was not taught to
me
my parents thought it best that I
learned the language of the dominant
Society they thought it would help me
succeed in this society I guess the
government did a good job on my parents
my people are different
we believe in the larger plan of the
creator military convoys the Soyuz
vehicle leads and in combat units
because our create to leave no one
behind
in our warrior society the greatest feat
in battle was not to kill your enemy the
greatest feat in battle was to lay a
hand on your enemy a tribute to your
skill and courage it appears that the
dominant Society is trying to leave some
of us behind but I am not worried the
Creator has brought me close close
enough to touch the enemy I'll close
with these questions what opportunities
has a creator given you and what will
you do when given the opportunity to
touch the enemy thank you
[Applause]
thank you Bruce once again I would like
to thank both Nicholas Pearce and Bruce
Webster for those wonderful remarks and
for letting the words of dr. King be
heard once more I hope that everyone
here today really had a chance to listen
carefully now I have the honor of
introducing Chancellor Philip M clay who
will recognize the 2004 MLK Leadership
Awards Chancellor clay thank you very
much
last evening we had the opportunity to
have a dinner at which we honored this
year's winners of the MLK Leadership
Awards the basis for these awards were
detailed and last week's issue of Tech
Talk and I won't detail them here but I
do want to introduce them to you and I
do want to emphasize that this is an
award for leadership which reflects a
combination of their service and their
commitment to the values that dr. King
represented so let me ask each Award
winner to stand as I read their name
Larousse McPhee McAfee
dr. Salvatore Malika
Dean latch Staton
and professor Phillip Thompson
these are our 2004 Award winners
congratulations thank you very much
thank you very much and congratulations
to the recipients of the awards I would
like at this time to welcome mr. Ronald
Hopkins who will sing a musical
selection in tribute to dr. king
so even though we face the difficulties
of today and tomorrow I still have a
dream it is a dream deeply rooted in the
American dream I have a dream that one
day this nation will rise up live out
the true meaning of its Creed we hold
these truths to be self-evident that all
men are created
[Music]
[Applause]
I have a dream that one day on the Red
Hills
[Music]
table of brotherhood I have a dream
pressure's low take our heads and unite
them together
as one
where we stay
to be just
[Music]
character
in your eyes lord
[Music]
we should love all all of our sisters
and
[Music]
there we live in a world
and unity
I wanna be free
gotta be free
we good Almighty
[Music]
I have a dream
oh yes I do
[Music]
[Applause]
out of vision the people will perish and
without home
there will be no
so we must teach our children
and learn from the past build a
foundation to help the next generation
Lord in your eyes
the man is above another
[Music]
all of us
then we shall be free one day
[Music]
I wanna be free
gotta be free
[Music]
Hey
I have a dream
[Music]
let me ring from the cabbage of trucks
of California
[Music]
oh yes
oh yes you can
[Music]
we can't live
Thank You mr. Hopkins for that wonderful
selection now president vest will give
some remarks and proceed to introduce
our keynote speaker dr. Julianne
Malveaux president Fez
[Applause]
Thank You Veronica and thank all of you
for joining us this morning to celebrate
the life and vision the Reverend dr.
Martin Luther King jr. in addition to
students faculty and staff here at MIT
I'm especially pleased to welcome this
morning to our event city councilor EDA
nice
Simmonds Denise thank you for joining us
MIT has been holding this celebration
for 30 years that's a large chunk of our
history and for 14 of those years Becky
and I have had the honor of hosting it
it has become for us and for the entire
community
a warm important moment in the annual
cycle of our University and a powerful
reminder of some of our deepest values
and most important responsibilities we
have met and listened to important
leaders of America's history creators of
our essence we have been inspired and
renewed my only complaint is that each
year for several weeks after this moment
in February I can't get the strains of
lift every voice and sing out of my mind
and can't concentrate on anything else I
suspect some of you share that with me
but as an annual event there's a danger
and that danger is captured in the title
the organizers chose for this year's
breakfast rhetoric or reality annual
renewal is extremely important for a
long and frustrating journey
but there must indeed be a reality as
well as a rhetoric so what about this
period of 30 years
think about MIT in 1974 and it's hard to
imagine that we are in the same place of
course in so many ways we are not the
same today as we were then in 1974 over
95% of our faculty were men
predominantly white men fewer than 3% of
our faculty were african-americans
Hispanic Native Americans and what did
our students look like in 1974 forgive
me but it is MIT and I'm going to talk a
little bit about numbers because that is
part of the reality in 1974 about 12% of
the undergraduate and graduate students
were women about 5% of our students
almost entirely undergraduates were
people of color when Becky and I came to
MIT in 1990 things had changed quite a
bit in some respects thanks to the
leadership of people like Paul Gray and
so many others who are in fact with us
here today
women had moved from 12% to 34% of our
undergraduate student body and to 20% of
our graduate students and 10% of our
faculty underrepresented minorities had
moved from five percent to 14 percent of
our undergraduates had become about
three percent of our graduate students
and still only about three percent of
our faculty so what is this part of the
reality today in 2004 women are 42
percent of our undergraduates nearly 29
percent of our graduates to
and just over 17 percent of our faculty
african-americans Latinos Native
Americans add up to nearly 20% of our
undergraduates four and a half percent
of our graduate population but just over
four percent of the faculty looking back
at the proportion of women and
minorities in our community over 30
years the picture is clear enormous
progress for women undergraduates good
progress for women and graduate programs
some progress for women in our faculty
and what about the groups that we are
here to think about today are members of
various underrepresented groups good
progress that we can be proud of at the
undergraduate level a little at the
graduate and faculty levels in short
even as we move forward with building
diversity and success at the
undergraduate level it is clear that
improvements in the undergraduate
enrollment over this period simply have
not easily or automatically translated
into progress in our graduate population
and in our faculty you all know that I'm
an optimist however so I can't resist
looking at the other half of the cup and
noting that while these fractions show
little growth for our underrepresented
minority and our graduate and faculty
populations there has in fact been a
significant growth in absolute numbers
between 1990 and today a 73% increase in
the number of minority graduate students
from 163 to 282 and a 48% increase in
the number of minority faculty from 27
to 40 and despite the small size of
these numbers that growth is important
because every number represents an
individual human being whose life
and contributions are precious still I
have to say that the one area I believe
I really have not succeeded in as your
president is that we have not
accelerated the racial diversity of our
faculty or for that matter a graduate
student body we simply must work harder
and more creatively to sustain the
progress that we've made at the
undergraduate level and to improve our
graduate populations and make faculty
careers viable and attractive for the
full spectrum of people in American
society this imperative as those who
spoke before me today have made clear is
made even tougher by the turn of events
in the last few years it seems to me
that as the summit of the mountain we
are climbing it's begun to come into
distant view the slope is getting
steeper and others are strewing rocks in
our path first challenges to
universities abilities and right to
select their own students according to
the criteria that best support their
educational mission second challenges to
our programs of outreach mentoring to
younger students and third international
security concerns that are translating
into barriers for students faculty and
scholars who wish to come here from
other countries now people of goodwill
can and indeed do differ politically and
philosopher and philosophically about
how to achieve the goal of a more
equitable society one in which our
colleges and universities more
accurately reflect the face the reality
of America but I have to say that there
is also a mean-spiritedness abroad in
our land one that has given voice
power by people who in fact do not agree
with our goal let alone how to reach it
but the one thing we cannot do is
pretend that the goal has been met and
that further explicit work is not needed
when it comes to college admissions the
modest gains that have been made in the
last decade are fragile in my experience
these gains are largely the result of
specific outreach mentoring and constant
attention to seek out inspire and I
really want to underline that word
inspire and support the very best
minority students I have seen nothing in
my career as an educator that suggests
that eliminating targeted efforts will
produce anything other than a slowing or
reversal the gains that we have made
when we gathered this time last year our
ability to consider race as one of many
factors in college admissions was
totally at risk as the Supreme Court
considered the challenges to affirmative
action that were raised in the two
lawsuits against the University of
Michigan in science and engineering
especially were the numbers of students
entering these fields is declining it is
more important than ever that we are
able to draw on the talents of our
entire population and this still in my
view requires special efforts if we are
to have that ability the good news on
the legal front is that we won last
year's Supreme Court rulings in the
Michigan case were a clear endorsement
of admissions practices like those here
at MIT in which we use race explicitly
but as one of many factors in selecting
our entering class when we choose each
class we first narrow the pool to those
whose grades class
ranked record etc show that they have
the ability to succeed and to contribute
to MIT but then the tough work begins we
have to make the difficult subjective
choices from among this group to select
that roughly 14 percent who we will
actually admit and we have to do this by
assessing as best we can the whole
person where they came from the
challenges and opportunities they have
encountered the contributions they made
to their communities and families their
zeal for learning the creativity their
determination and so forth but knowing a
student's race in America today is
clearly one of the elements that helped
us to form an understanding of each
individual I have no illusion that after
the Michigan decision there will not be
future challenges to affirmative action
and other targeted efforts by colleges
to admit the best classes for our
programs but I am equally confident that
MIT will continue to uphold the
principles in which we believe and that
have served us by the way have served us
so well we can hope that Sandra Day
O'Connor was right when she expressed
the hope that in 25 years we will no
longer need affirmative action programs
but today we still need these particular
targeted efforts if we are to reach our
societal goals and make no doubt about
it we must be prepared to deal with
continuing tests of our resolve which
are likely to come especially in the
form of referenda in the States and in
assaults on our programs of outreach to
high school students
indeed as has already been stated this
morning some of these programs here and
elsewhere already find themselves in
very murky political and legal waters in
the early nineteen seven
these MIT established outreach and
mentoring and enrichment programs to
attract young Latino african-american
Native American high school students to
the engineering profession though these
are populations that had not tended to
view engineering as a particularly
obvious or attractive career I don't
believe that we and other universities
saw this task is one of political
orientation or ideology we saw it as a
part of our responsibility to provide
all of our students with rich and full
and educational experience as possible
as well as to meet our responsibility to
prepare a professional workforce and
future leadership that reflects the face
of America during the last two decades
however we have come up against the last
two years
we have come up against serious legal
challenges to such efforts as most of
you know a complaint filed against us by
two special interest groups led to the
Office of Civil Rights the department of
education to review two of our
pre-college summer programs meit's and
project interphase these two programs
have served over a thousand promising
young men and women very well in light
of these legal challenges however and
please believe me with the very best
advice of every legal expert we sought
out we concluded that we should not
continue to limit participation in these
programs exclusively to underrepresented
minority students we indeed broadened
the selection criteria to include other
students whose backgrounds might
otherwise stand in the way of their
studying science and engineering
mathematics but who also support the
basic goals of the programs in making
these changes we will ensure that these
programs
continue to serve their original goal
because they created an inspiration and
opportunity for young people of color
and they have not destroyed opportunity
for any one else my fear and presumably
the aim of some others is that over time
such diffusion of effort will wear down
the gains that we and others have worked
so hard for so many years to establish
these two areas of challenge admissions
and outreach programs illustrate a very
real dilemma we are expected by our
society even today and indeed by the
federal government to advance diversity
and opportunity in science and
engineering in fact in this strange
world of 2004 we are given mandates by
the federal funding agencies to reach
out and engage minorities and women and
people with disabilities in the work of
our research programs and research
centers that they fund and we are
expected to be accountable for producing
results but at the same time we are
warned by the same government that
targeting such efforts to specific
populations we are supposed to advance
in ways that we know work will not be
acceptable under current interpretation
of the law this ambiguity this catch-22
is simply bizarre we are being told to
reach explicit goals but not to make
explicit effort to achieve them a
similar dilemma can be found these days
with regard to international students
and scholars we know that in a great
university in the 21st century there are
many dimensions to the diversity that
their lives and scholarship the openness
of us research universities to students
and scholars from other countries has
been overwhelmingly successful in
building the excellence of our
institutions enhancing the educational
experience of our students contributing
to American industry and society and
building goodwill for the us around the
world here at MIT our Nobel Prize
recipients include faculty colleagues
who were born in Japan and India and
Mexico Italy and Germany as well as in
the u.s. an American industry relies
greatly on engineers and computer
scientists born in other countries most
of whom came here as graduate students
there are signs however that responses
to the obviously legitimate heightened
concerns about our national security are
rapidly undermining a great source of
our vitality international students
scholars and visitors to the US were
subjected to new reviews interviews
delays and much more frequent denials of
visas and we are seeing efforts to
restrict the involvement of foreign
students in certain areas of study or
research despite the fact that they are
not classified and that we do not do
classified research on our campus during
the last year and I want to be clear
about this during the last year the
government did make numerous
improvements in process and policy but
nonetheless the number of students and
scholars coming to the u.s. is trending
downward but the more important issue is
whether there are changes in the quality
of international students and scholars
coming here will our universities
continue to be magnets for the best and
brightest students not only from every
corner of our nation but every corner of
our world
now you might ask why bring
international politics into today's
discussion but I want to remind you of
something that dr. King said dr. King
said we all came in different ships but
were in the same boat now diversity is
one of this nation's greatest strengths
and diversity by its very nature is
broadly encompassing and the principles
are the same and what is happening in
the name of Homeland Security represents
a major challenge to diversity spoken
broadly it puts me in mind of a
character in Finian's Rainbow who said
an immigrant damn my family's been
having trouble with immigrants ever
since we came to this country so I urge
you all to be cognizant of and cherish
the great value to be found in the broad
openness of our universities and because
of the particular history of our country
however we must pay particular attention
to diversity as it applies to race in
America the inroads made by
underrepresented minority groups into
higher education and careers and science
and engineering or fragile they have
resulted from deliberate concerted
attention and actions we must work
together to open opportunities and
encourage careers and science and
engineering to everyone who has the
interest and ability to pursue this path
and our actions at the undergraduate
level must be accompanied by equally
strong efforts to bring greater racial
and ethnic diversity to our graduate
programs and our faculty we have not
succeeded in these dimensions pure and
simple for graduate students one
immediate goal should be to increase the
yield from among the graduate students
whom we admit our own graduate student
council has presented this case
in a very compelling manner and we need
to follow through persuading more
students to accept our invitation
requires above all a personal touch and
frankly the same is true a faculty
recruitment it's simply not enough as it
may have been in an earlier era to make
an offer and simply expect that everyone
will jump at the opportunity to come to
MIT again it calls for us to pick up the
phone make the case why that person
should be here and to ask how we can
help him or her choose us
it means inviting them to meet future
colleagues putting together startup
packages that say we want you here now
while I do not hide behind it
the fact is that the national poll of
faculty and science and engineering is
woefully inadequate and that even as we
improve to strut as we struggle to
improve the diversity of faculty the
strategic key the strategic key is to
increase the Graduate populations in
these fields around the country the
progress we have made can be credited
not so much to institutional programs
although they surely have their part as
to individual vidual commitment
perseverance and leadership where there
has been change it has been the result
of individual leadership on the part of
department heads and faculty but to
really succeed we have to go beyond
developing or sustaining admissions and
outreach programs for students
recruiting more faculty of color these
are necessary steps their metrics but
they are only first steps the real
challenge does not lie outside our walls
the real challenge lies within our
hearts and it lies in the expectations
we set for our students and for
ourselves
in the ways we teach in the amount of
time and effort we give to supporting
our students and colleagues the progress
that has been made has been the result
of institutional programs and individual
efforts and scores of ways mentoring a
junior colleague inviting a student into
a research project or study group
providing financial support extending a
hand and friendship
taking the risk to get to know someone
of a different culture or religion or
race
we have been through some difficult
times on the racial front over these
years and I sometimes as I'm sure you do
get discouraged that we will ever
eradicate the ignorance and Prejudice
that keep us from being all that we can
be with and for each other but we have
had some moments of which we can be
proud as well I think about the ways in
which our community came together after
September 11th 2001 reaching out and
supporting one another at that terrible
time we shouldn't need a crisis to bring
us together in our everyday lives
we should celebrate learning about and
with each other and as I said in my
inaugural address 13 years ago such
change is rewarding but seldom easy
during the years ahead we must refuse to
let the centrifugal forces of
intolerance and injustice pull us apart
we must be held together by respect for
the individual and by a commitment to
those values we hold in common that was
our challenge then it is their challenge
today thank you for being here and thank
you very much for 14 years of
inspiration of challenge
and hope thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
that now it now gives me great pleasure
now gives me great pleasure to introduce
our keynote speaker dr. Julianne
Malveaux dr. Malvo who received her PhD
in economics from MIT is a noted author
and commentator on economic and social
issues particularly those relating to
race and gender she is a producer of
public affairs programming for the
Public Broadcasting System a
self-described mad economist she is a
regular columnist for USA Today black
issues in higher education and more than
20 newspapers around the country and she
is a frequent contributor to such
national magazines as essence MS crisis
black enterprise and others she serves
on the boards of many national
organizations devoted to policy and
action on economic and social issues and
as chair of the board of directors of
the National Child Labor Committee and
in coming to MIT this week she is on
familiar academic ground having taught
at Berkeley Stanford and the College of
Notre Dame please join me in welcoming
this morning's keynote speaker dr.
Julianne Malveaux
[Applause]
[Music]
good morning y'all got to talk to me
good morning president fest thank you
very much both for the warm introduction
and for the update on what's happening
here in MIT I speak all over the country
so I'm kind of used to speaking but I
was not expecting the waves of nostalgia
as I listen to you talk about MIT the
challenges and having diverse admissions
and some of the issues that we've been
facing over the years I came to MIT in
1974 partially thanks to a woman who's
here the audience Linda Sharpe I don't
know if she remembers writing me a
letter when I was an undergraduate
student at BC saying please come to MIT
the outreach situation was one that made
it difficult for me to say no although
some of my conservative colleagues in
the economics profession
now assert that I probably am not really
an economist but something else because
of the work that I do on politics but
Linda a belated thank you very much for
reaching out to me the lots of other
friends of long standing on I use that
word old anymore after you have certain
birthdays you don't use the word old but
friends have long standing the audience
and they're probably too many to mention
I just want to say that it is good to be
back at MIT is it is a place of
nostalgia I don't know how many of you
remember dr. Phyllis Wallace who was a
professor in the Sloan School and a
mentor to me and I probably would not
have finished her were it not for dr.
Wallace for one thing I never knew
another african-american woman economist
and at the times that I thought about
well maybe I'll go to law school well
maybe I'll go into the media she sort of
say no you're gonna finish this degree
but she wasn't really then do whatever
you want you know she was a really
special person a special to so many of
us and a real giver and mentor and role
model for all of us the question that's
been raised today is a question about
civil rights under siege and before I
continue I just have to just acknowledge
the student speakers this morning both
of you gave me a lot to think about
we're excellent orator and with searing
commentary about our times especially
want to
now my long-standing thinkit's and we
have to look at this to remember the
young man's name Bruce I was really
touched by what you had to say about our
nation's hypocrisy touched all the more
so because you're a veteran one of my
recent books is called the paradox of
loyalty an african-american response to
the war on terrorism african-american
men constantly fought for the right to
fight as did native men for the right to
fight for the right to be in our armies
and so in fighting for the right to
fight exhibiting the ultimate for I
think of patriotism and yet finding it
rewarded in very poignant ways and in
fact unrewarded the you you really
touched my soul and I really want to
thank you for that
[Applause]
the question that we raised this morning
are are our civil rights under siege and
the answer is of course they're under
siege directly and they're under siege
indirectly many have mentioned the
Michigan case and the Michigan case is a
cornerstone for two reasons one Sandra
Day O'Connor said is going to take 25
years well how does she know of course
this is the same person who said in the
crocin case that people could not prove
past discrimination now she is writing
about a case in Richmond Virginia in
other words the bass head of the
Confederacy and she's asking black
people who have gotten minority business
set-asides to prove discrimination I
think my very tongue-in-cheek comment at
the time was shall I show you the chains
in any case she doesn't know what's
going to happen but what the Michigan
cases do are raised questions about the
very fabric of our society and a whole
set of entitlements that we need to
begin to look at when you looked at the
plaintiffs in Michigan they were whiners
I mean what was wrong with these people
I mean they truly thought that they were
entitled to slats at the University of
Michigan entitled and because they
didn't get them they were going to sue
this is how we've ended up with such a
litigious society if I don't get my way
I'll sue there X number of slots there
were people that were white people who
scored more lowly than they did but were
admitted so this was just this misplaced
sense of entitlement that's quite
fascinating but the unmentioned issue
here is a center for individual rights
the center for individual rights which
is funded with corporate dollars some of
the same corporations that support us
with progressive work also support the
Center for individual rights that goes
around plaintiffs plaintiffs shopping
looking for aggrieved white people that
they can file lawsuits on behalf of I
would warrant that these were some of
the people who follow the lawsuits
against interphase in the in the minor
program and those people are they're
evil and evil seems like a I mean
because they literally are stuck they
have decided that they want to turn the
clock back they make a series of
disingenuous arguments and we have
failed that only a to call them on it
but B to call their corporate friends on
it what we need to do is look at who was
funding them look at who is funding them
I mean chorus is a great example I'll
pick on course for a minute because
Korres is now running around saying
we're ok we don't discriminate anymore
we're not mad at unions no but we give 5
million dollars a year to the Center for
individual rights well at some level no
you don't have to pick on unions just
pick on black folks now literally we
need to look at who these corporations
are and call them on it you can't have a
King Day celebration one day and fund
the people who are trying to dismantle
the dream the next day and that's part
of what's happening the other thing that
seemed to me to be interesting about the
Michigan case with the sense of
entitlement was the extent to which
people don't look at this notion of
fairness with balance in other words the
process of putting together a college
class is almost like the process of
composing a symphony you would not want
a college class that had 1,000 people
with 1,600 SATs on them they might be
brilliant but some of them would be
awfully boring
we know this we're at MIT but we know
that we want to look at as they do in
the state of Michigan we want to look at
making sure people who are rural are
there as well as people who are urban
people of color as well as others one of
the things that no one's complained
about what the Michigan case is this
thing called Chancellor's preference you
got 20 points for race but you also got
20 points for this thing called
Chancellor's preference which mean the
Chancellor could be reading the Detroit
Free Press and find that there's a
violinist who seems wonderful with a C+
average and said let me give them my 20
Chancellor's preference plays because we
want to buy a list well if you can cut
and paste these things for violinists
and alumni and football players and you
name it
why can't you parse it for race well we
know that we can talk about the tax
dollars of people of color going to
support institutions that exclude us
now I don't want us if I'm not going to
spend all my time talking about
affirmative action but I think it
important also to be clear about what
else is happening in higher education
because it's connected
lots of our attention goes on
affirmative action and he lead
institutions like MIT but the bulk of
african-american students are going to
start out at community colleges and
state institutions and what's happening
there because our president well let me
see I really don't usually call him the
president I call him the resident cuz he
just lives there I mean like he just
moved animals like abandoned housing
your urban studies professor you have
the status thing of a band that had yo
Clinton laughs nobody Gordon moving fast
enough so he moved in turned on the
utilities and there he is you know and
then spending billions of tax dollars on
these tax cut proposals that have put
our budget in jeopardy and 40 of our 50
states are in economic jeopardy and what
this has meant at the state level is
that people are cutting everything and
so in some states you have double-digit
increases in tuitions at state
universities in New York State a 40% for
0 a 40% increase in the tuition here in
Massachusetts I believe it was something
around 20% and Ohio it was 22% New
Mexico I think was the best state they
had 2% increase but there are more than
15 states that had double-digit
increases in tuition increases in
tuitions cuts and financial aid and more
and more students of color are saying we
can't go to school so we must focus on
the elite institutions because they're
important because they set policy
because they lead the way and we count
on these institutions president vests to
take the legal risks to assemble the
legal teams MIT and Harvard can do it
easier in the State University at
Northridge can we count on them to do
that but we also have to look at the
total fabric of our society and what's
happening with public higher education
and what's happening is that people are
being locked away locked out because of
the crazy policies
of this administration now we know that
we're no weapons of mass distraction
could have told you that a long time ago
you know and then just be let's just
pray that mr. Bush does not pull a bin
Laden out of his hat on Halloween you
know as he goes into the election with
the polls against him oh I found it I
can tell you maybe where Osama bin Laden
is see I think he's in Detroit I think
he got a haircut
I think he's pumping gas at a 7-eleven
and Davis sister named Mabel this is
what I think I don't know this but the
middle-eastern population of Detroit is
quite high and disprove it I mean did
this prove it start going to 7-elevens I
mean I shouldn't say that too loud or
Ashcroft might try that
he tried just about everything else but
in any case what we know is that these
tax policies combined with the money we
spent on toppling Saddam Hussein a
hundred and eighty billion dollars the
money that we spent has had a
deleterious effect on the quality of
lives especially of people at the bottom
that the monies that have been spent
have been monies that have literally
been spent to dismantle the dream I
don't know quite how we decided that dr.
King's dream from the 1963 speech would
be most of what we would focus on but
when we get to January 15th everybody
plays the quote and of course dr. King
had such a sonorous voice and he was
such a veteran that it makes sense and
we all enjoy it I have a dream wonderful
song incidentally I enjoyed that too I
have a dream that people will be judged
you know by the content of their
character and not the color of their
skin yes he said that
but that literally is the least of what
he said if you simply focus on that you
have missed dr. King in the very same
speech in the very same speech he said
we have come to our nation's capital to
cash a check and the check has been
marked insufficient funds
now if you said if you thought cash a
check every time you heard I have a
dream imagine how different our society
would be see I allege all the times it's
an act of professional chauvinism but I
really sure dr. Martin Luther King was
an economist you know I mean everybody
wants to claim him the religious
community claims in you know the
inspirational community claims and I was
in Venezuela a month ago I went to
Venezuela to celebrate dr. King's
birthday Hugo Chavez has claimed dr.
Martin Luther King as an icon in
Venezuela so everybody can find some of
dr. King that they like but I would
encourage you to read him in total do
not just read that 1963 speech indeed if
you have time and get his the book a
testament of hope that has everything in
it and read it from cover to cover the
Playboy magazine interview of 1968 is
absolutely inspirational his Nobel Peace
Prize acceptance speech is what I use to
establish his economic credentials when
he accepted the Nobel Peace Prize he
said I have the audacity to believe that
people everywhere can have three meals a
day for their bodies Education and
Culture for their minds peace and
freedom for their spirits I have the
audacity to believe that people
everywhere can have three meals a day
for their bodies we have now still
millions of Americans who go hungry can
you believe that we have hunger still in
America people who still don't have
clean water in parts of these United
States Education and Culture for their
minds he said and yet how many people
are denied access to equal education I'm
talking and then you have mr. Bush's let
leave no child behind I mean my
tongue-in-cheek interpretation of that
is let every child kiss my behind
because
if you look at what he's done with
monies you can have money for testing
every other year but not money for
teachers and materials money for tea so
you're subsidizing the testing industry
and who wants a loan kindergarten first
grade second grade child to be judged
with the pencil can they put the circles
incorrectly well what we need to do is
talk about materials programming we have
not been able to get to wire inner city
schools for internet access not that the
internet is a basic right but it's very
interesting Bruce when you talked about
SAT prep prep classes and other classes
you have people who can pay thousands of
dollars for SAT prep and some who have
no prep and this is how the gap
continues to be widened so he said
education and culture we still don't
have that and peace and freedom I mean
can we talk about peace and freedom
today what our country aggressively
decided and you know that's how do you
spell you know weapons of mass
destruction
oh I L how do you spell weapons of mass
destruction a burden just had to give
back just had to give back 26 million
dollars for overcharging the United
States government for meals that they
never served in Iraq charging almost $3
a gallon for oil when is I've you know I
just try to figure these kinds of things
out they truly baffle my brain they
really really do I'm speaking of
affirmative action and baffling one's
brain you know when mr. Bush went to
Yale and said you too can be the
president with a C average I thought yes
only if you have no melanin in your skin
I mean that was the most powerful
affirmative action program I've ever
seen it Yale how do you admit bush but
back to dr. King I couldn't help that
but in any case when you look at that
Nobel Peace Prize acceptance speech dr.
King has laid out for us a plan what we
need to do dr. King talked about our
economic system in ways that were
absolutely revolutionary he said in 1968
and where do we go from here there 40
million poor people in America and you
have to ask yourself this question what
kind of society produces 40 million poor
people and when you ask the question
then you have to ask about the basic
structure of our economy if he goes on
to say who owns the oil who owns the
iron or if the world is two-thirds water
said dr. King why do we pay water bills
don't send that to the water company it
will not work but it's a question worth
asking in terms of distribution it's a
question that he asked throughout his
life yes he started out as a country
preacher trying to get people from the
back of the bus to the front but he
evolved into someone who not only cared
about the economic structure of our
country but the economic inequalities
that persists in our world and he talked
about and he's got it in your program
it's one of his great quotes about the
tranquilizing drug of gradualism so you
have all this churn about micro change
the illusion of change he talked so much
about those kinds of things and that's
the king we want to ignore you know all
the people I didn't you know reasonable
people have room for reasonable
disagreement but it fascinates me that
dr. King has now become a great American
hero so much so that Walmart that does
not pay people especially undocumented
immigrant people reasonable wages lots
people up in in in their building so
that they can work all night and not
leave now Walmart takes out full-page
ads we do have a dream what dream
you know that that big Donaldson and
Burger King to have a dream but
everybody would get fat you know that
everybody claims a dream without looking
at the text and the subtext you know it
is almost an Americanism to have sales
in your name you have Presidents Day
sales and Mother's Day sales and now you
have dr. Martin Luther King Day sales
there is a man in Washington DC who has
a first sale if you are a first sale
every King's birthday now for about the
last five years until last year I
decided I would stop because if I have
loser wouldn't go in anywhere with them
I call him and say do you understand the
irony of what you're doing you know this
this is Miss Malvo remember the lady who
called you last year do you understand
the irony and he sort of talked to me
for a few minutes and he said it's the
crazy lady again but the temerity of
someone to sell fur a symbol in a badge
of elitism to sell fur on dr. King's
birthday to have a fur sale
so somehow we've given dr. King this
great American designation but we
forgotten what he said so if we remember
what he said we might not even be
sitting here we'd be out somewhere doing
something about what's going on dr. King
literally deplored gradualism he was
livid at the system the young man you
talked about his quote of
dissatisfaction that's when he talked
about let us be eternally dissatisfied
but we're not eternally dissatisfied
it's okay
I mean he literally was repelled by what
we are doing as a country
he said about poverty the curse of
poverty is an abomination in our age it
is as but did he say if it is as
desperate as the practice of cannibalism
he'd like in poverty to cannibalism
people eating people at the turn of the
century just imagine that now we walk by
poor people we don't want to give them
spare change in my hometown of San
Francisco Willie Brown who I almost love
actually how I actually had a piece of
legislation that outlawed what they
called agree
panhandling now I'm not sure how you do
passive panhandling you know you sort of
hold you the hands toward the person say
off uh-huh
think you know you hope that somehow
they'll get it and share but you know
people I'm I've paying handlers because
they remind me that we can't forget
about the poor and yes pan handlers
raise questions for us some of them are
drunks some of them are drug addicts
some of them are crazy but guess what
poverty will make you crazy you know
homelessness will make you crazy and so
it's something that's very recursive
that we've decided we don't pay
attention to you know I thought about
dr. King very recently when I saw Judith
Dean on the on television now I'm not a
Dean fan I think he is crazy but I think
that she is a very articulate and
principled woman who said I am NOT a
thing person but we are a thing nation
she said I am NOT a thing person so her
husband gave her a Bush for the
anniversary it's alright wasn't her
birthday
whatever she got a bush I'm not into
things you looked at her and she wasn't
dripping with gold or diamonds she she
was taking care of people well dr. King
said is how we have elevated things over
people machines and computers over
people we have our thin society not a
people society we elevate profits over
people and because we do that we end up
with this system of exploitation not
only here but abroad why did September
11th happen I don't know but I know one
thing I know that when my 77 year old
mother heard that happened she said what
took him so long not because she was
happy we actually lost a distant
relative there not because she was happy
not because she was rejoicing but
because you cannot have affluence and
poverty coexist next to each other when
46 percent of the people in this world
live on less than $2 a day do you hear
me live on less than $2 a day and when
they are constantly treated to our
invasive culture which comes to their
countries courtesy of
in HBO b ET mtv I mean imagine being on
the African continent and watching
somebody shaking their booty to be
eating well there's no water there I
mean it's kind of like you know you
think you're sort of in some kind of
science fiction novel but when you have
so many people earning so little money
and being so constantly disregarded by
our society yeah they're mad at us black
folks will understand this because we
all have read the Langston Hughes story
of the preacher who came to your house
you know back in the south back in the
day on Sunday
the preachers will come to your house
and you couldn't eat until the preacher
ate
okay in the United States is like the
big fat preacher who came at to eat sat
down ate one side of the breasts didn't
the other side one leg than the other
leg one thigh than the other thigh one
wing than other and left the back they
say y'all have a good day
that's literally what our nation does in
terms of resources and those of you have
you seen that preacher you know you just
hope that your momma held some of the
food back so is there anything else for
the snow because he ate too much of you
no human being could eat that much
chicken but they did and that's the
United States I think the rest of the
world looks and it says no one country
can inhale that many of our world's
resources but we do not only do we
inhale the resources but then we deal in
an arrogance I don't know why September
11th happened but I know that the week
before we walked out of the world
conference against racism left I know
that the person that we sent to lead
that delegation was not our best in our
brightest we sent a deputy assistant
secretary now I'm not disrespecting a
deputy assistant secretary there was a
point in my life when I wanted to be one
but this is like a new PhD young white
man with a new PhD who was leading the
delegation so he doesn't know which way
is up or down he's just there he calls
why should they say leave he leaves
literally the United States did not
participate we said to the rest of the
world forget you we're not thinking
about you know I don't think that all of
those things are the reason this
happened and
September 11th was probably one of the
most horrible days that our nation has
experienced or these are some people in
our nation have experienced the other
people have experienced horrible days
before you talked about the Holocaust
Bruce there has been several Holocaust
in this country we talk about domestic
terrorism there's this thing called
Tulsa Oklahoma 1921 where the United
States government dropped bombs on black
people in their own community in their
own community out of economic envy
because they were mad that black people
had too much money so we people have
experienced terrorism Cornel West said
in the wake of September 11 that
everybody knows how it feels to be black
in other words not to know what's gonna
happen next you know not to know what's
next not to know what's up not only to
be black but to be part of any other
country now we know how it feels to live
in Israel you get on the bus and you
don't know if the bus is gonna get there
or if the bus is gonna get you you
literally have no idea but people there
keep living and so have we have we learn
from September 11th president fest I
don't think so like like the MIT
community people all over the United
States pull together we started talking
about the same boat but when I get the
same boat cold I always think yeah we're
all in the same boat but some people are
riding and some folks are rolling you
know some folks are coasting and some
folks are working and we see that but we
all came together as a nation we're all
touched and moved and now we're back to
our same always
nobody is angry about poverty we have 10
million Americans 10 million who earn
less than five dollars and 15 cents an
hour who haven't had a raise since 1996
and excuse my Ebonics but ain't nobody
mad people look at that and say oh well
maybe they didn't work hard enough let
me tell you something people have
minimum-wage jobs work real hard they
are among the hardest working Americans
they are and just imagine this for a low
minute
[Applause]
what if minimum-wage workers all
disappeared what will we do how will we
live
who would pour our coffee throw our
newspapers park our cars take care of
our aging parents and our children those
are the people who earn the minimum wage
dr. King did not die dreaming he won't
sleep he died trying to raise the
workers wages rather of garbage workers
in Memphis Tennessee where the black men
were black men were being paid less than
$1 an hour in 1968 while white men were
being paid about a dollar 65 now nobody
was getting rich I warrant you that but
look at that pay disparity another part
of the disparity was this the black men
in inclement weather could be sent home
so they didn't work which but they
didn't get paid while the white men were
sent inside to do work those men walked
around with signs that said I am a man
when I was 12 13 years old I don't know
or saw the signs when this was happening
and I said to my mother well that's
obvious they're men you know teenagers
are very flippant so go that's obvious
why do they have signs that say I am a
man but then when I began to read the
history was clear because they were not
treated as men they weren't treated as
human beings they weren't treated as
people they were dealt with as if they
had no dignity we still do that we still
treat poor people as if they have no
dignity no rights as if they're not our
fellow Americans and we do it callously
and casually and we don't even care and
if we care it's episodic caring like the
quarter you put in someone's hand that
begins to do something but it doesn't do
much King said on one hand you're called
upon to play a Good Samaritan on life's
roadside but that will only be an
initial act one day we must come to see
that the hold Jericho Road must be
transformed so that men and women will
not be constantly beaten and robbed as
they make their journey on life's
highway constantly beaten and robbed the
ways that we treat poor people and the
trick bags that American capitalist and
puts poor people in are things that we
need to investigate the entirety
the credit card society credit nation is
something that is like pop at an
additional shackle for the poor we are
as dr. King said a thing
culture we feel good we buy we feel bad
we buy we get a new job we need new
clothes for our new job we lose our job
we need new clothes because you can't
wear those other give you casual clothes
so you have to go buy some casual
clothes no matter what we do our
response our program response is we buy
the irony of course is that our economy
expands when people spend money that
two-thirds our economy base is based on
increased spending but somehow how do we
control the fact that we are asking
people even forcing people to spend when
they don't have the means to pay it back
the credit card industry sent out 400
million credit cards last year netted
only about a hundred and sixty million
adults I didn't say credit worthy adults
I said adults who qualify for critical
who are over you know over 18 whatever
my 20 year old nephew got a credit card
application it was so funny he called me
every sound Juliana he was so happy he
said Bank of America wants to give me a
thousand dollars I said bad I was in a
meeting and he calls me on my cell to
tell me this I have to excuse myself I
said baby read the fine print well now I
say yeah now so he got to the part about
the 24.9% he said but that's not fair I
said you know you sound like the white
folks fussing about affirmative action
no it's not fair but that's how it is so
guess what don't get the credit card but
these cards are pushed on folks and then
the the comes a spiral I was talking to
a woman a friend of mine the other day
who was actually a minimum wage worker
and she has to be credit cards and she
literally had me cracking up she said
that the credit card people had called
her because she was behind she's behind
because she has no health insurance when
her child broke his arm he was admitted
to the hospital with her credit card now
she's behind
she said the lady called her and said do
you know you're behind on your payment
she'll she said yes so she said well I
want to help you pay your bill she said
oh good
you gonna send me some money but what
they need my help you is they want to
figure out a way either to get in your
bank account what the what the credit
card person said to her was do you have
another credit card so how would you pay
one credit card with another credit card
and she was going to help her by setting
this up
electronically I said what did you tell
her she said she could help me by
sending five dollars I said you know the
problem is she makes as much money as
you do she doesn't have anything to send
you but this spiral of thing ism is
something we don't pay attention to
people at the bottom pay big interest
people at the top pay little interest
you know the level of our inequalities
reverberates go to inner cities and look
at the quality of grocery stores just
grocery stores go to suburbs and look at
the many options look at the prices at
inner city grocery stores go to suburbs
and look at the many options there's a
Costco in Pentagon city in DC and
there's a housing project there's no way
to get from the housing project to the
Costco but the person who needs 24 rolls
of toilet paper is the person has the
six kids
I don't need 24 girls are talking about
they have a co-op when I go to Costco
all my friends you want some toilet
paper you know I got 24 rolls you know
you come and get some toilet paper you
know they like what's wrong with job I
don't need that much but it was so cheap
you can hardly resist it the people who
needed other people who don't have
access to it and these access questions
are not the questions we're raising all
we've made so much progress so much
progress the signs don't say why to call
it anymore the question isn't whether or
not you ride in the back of the bus it's
do you have bus fare
do you own a bus company can use own the
buses those are the questions can you
determine which country you're importing
and exporting the bus parts from and
with what kind of tariffs and
protectionism those are now the
questions and if you think zoning is not
an issue
think about upstate New York where
Johnnie Cochran successfully defended or
or got a settlement for a family where
the woman lived in a housing project
single mom trying to raise herself up
and so was working in a department store
in a complex well the bus did not go
from a cop
from the housing project to the complex
because the complex did not want poor
people shopping there so this young
woman at 18 take the bus to across the
street and then run across a six-lane
highway to get to her job her minimum
wage job so she could get off public
assistance run across one day the
inevitable happened a truck hit her and
what they tried to argue is it was her
fault why wasn't she paying attention
Johnnie Cochran got her son two million
dollars thank the Lord for Johnnie
Cochran you know what that's what you
should get next time there's an
affirmative action but basically what we
see the challenges of the civil rights
struggle have changed so we're not just
talking about sides at the back of the
bus now we're talking about who gets to
go who gets to have access and whether
or not we care dr. King said the
economic highway to power has few entry
lanes for Negroes he said this in 1964
it's still the case today yes we have
black millionaires more of them than
ever yes they're highly celebrated yes
we have black poverty 25 percent black
population poor 40 percent of our
children and so when you look at a place
like MIT with considerable pride our
president vests that the work you've
done in your 14 years and
congratulations you also have to ask a
question about whether a young person
down the street Western Avenue has any
chance of coming to MIT we paid
attention to some of the issues but have
we paid attention to all of them and
this is the question I leave you with
King dr. King was not trying to do
something gradually he wasn't trying to
do something nicely he was killed trying
to do something in your face the Poor
People's Campaign plan to take six
thousand people to Washington DC to
occupy government offices to sit at HUD
we used to sit at HHS to sit in every
government office and demand that people
pay attention to these societal poverty
problems now didn't happen the way he
planned because he was killed
Apryl the movement did not have
basically the energy to take it on yes
the poor people campaign happen they did
have a tent city but it was much
different from what king had planned
he's he cared about this so much that in
the two weeks before his death but down
to the King Center looked at his
schedules in the week of March 23rd to
30th 1968 he gave 23 speeches in one
week he crisscross rural Georgia got on
a plane and went to LA was moving around
the country because he wanted us to feel
that we could change the system that in
eliminating and eradicating poverty here
we would take a first step from doing it
abroad as well that he was on fire about
that it wasn't something where he
thought he could sit down how many of us
feel that we want to change the system
so much that we will not rest we will
not sit down who in this room who in
this world has the audacity of a dr.
Martin Luther King see audacity means
nerve I have the nerve to believe me
you think you know you can pass his
little tax cut here you could raise the
minimum wage by 56 no he said people
everywhere can eat people everywhere can
be educated not on go pass some little
law that's what dr. King said and we
have to relate to that and if we don't
relate to that we shouldn't necessarily
think about that dreamer because there
was more to it than the dream here is
what he said and I'll close he he said I
choose to identify with the
underprivileged
I choose to identify with the poor I
choose to give my life for the hungry I
choose to give my life for those who've
been left out of the sunlight of
opportunity I choose to live for and
with those who find themselves seeing
life as a long and desolate corridor
with no exit sign this is the way I'm
going if it means suffering a little bit
I'm going that way if it means
sacrificing I'm going that way if it
means dying for them he said I'm going
that way because I heard a voice say do
something for others dr. Martin Luther
King was of black people but he did not
belong to us he belonged to a world that
needs to be readjusted a world that
needs to be restructured and rearranged
we celebrate him on a day like this we
have to ask what rearranging are we
willing to do thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you dr. Malvo for your heartfelt
words
Provost Robert Brown will now recognize
the 2003-2004 Martin Luther King jr.
visiting professors Provost Brown Thank
You Veronica
good morning all right we're getting
better it's a pleasure to have the
opportunity to introduce several of our
Martin Luther King fellows and scholars
that are with us this morning the MLK
visiting professor program was founded
in 1995 to bring the MIT black and
Hispanic scholars to enrich the
diversity of our academic community the
program has sponsored visiting faculty
in all five schools at MIT typically
candidates are nominated by individual
faculty members enjoying the faculty and
teaching staff of the of these
departments for the duration of their
stay while in the departments they
participate in teaching and research
interact with faculty undergraduate and
graduate students this year we have
seven visiting professors and scholars
in the program at MIT three of them are
with us this morning I will introduce
each of them who are sitting at the
table down below Professor Jonathan
Farley Jonathan Jonathan isn't is an
associate professor of mathematics at
the University of Vanderbilt who is
visiting in the department of
mathematics at MIT he did his
undergraduate work at Harvard University
and has a doctorate in mathematics from
Oxford he's been a Fulbright
distinguished scholar and a post
doctoral fellow in the mathematics
Research Institute at the University of
California at Berkeley welcome dr. Kofi
Maggio
professor Maggio hails from the
University of Cincinnati where is a
system professor in philosophy he's
visiting in the Department of
linguistics and philosophy of MIT he
holds undergraduate degrees in
philosophy and education from the
University of Benin and Togo and a
doctorate from the University of
Burgundy in France he's an expert in
contemporary philosophy of science as
well as the history of modern philosophy
and metaphysics finally I'd like to
introduce Britisher powell
patricia is visiting in the program in
writing in humanistic studies at MIT she
received her undergraduate degree from
Wellesley and it has an MFA from Brown
University Patricia is a prolific writer
of fiction having already published
three popular books and is working on a
fourth and has also published numerous
short pieces her academic focus is on
Caribbean American cultures she has
taught at both Harvard and the
University of Massachusetts before
coming to MIT please join me in
welcoming these people to our breakfast
into our community thank you
we will now have the MIT gospel choir
lead us in singing lift every voice and
sing by James Weldon Johnson we ask that
you join in and sing the first verse she
found on the back of your program
booklet please stand and join hands as
the song is sunk
[Music]
I would now like to continue with an
announcement relevant to our celebration
if you would look in the inside of your
program here the Martin Luther King jr.
IEP design seminar has an installation
in lobby 10 titled resurrection city and
MIT tribute to dr. King's Poor People's
Campaign now I would like to ask
Reverend Johanna Keith nur to come
forward to give the benediction to close
this morning's program
here words from Nelson Mandela the time
for healing of the wounds has come the
time to build is upon us we pledge
ourselves to liberate all our people
from the continuing bondage of poverty
deprivation suffering gender and other
discrimination there is no easy road to
freedom
none of us actin alone can achieve
success we must therefore act together
as a united people for reconciliation
for nation-building for the birth of a
new world and may the God who has birth
dust in the fire of freedom and justice
and peace encourage us in the work we do
and in the lives we lead that all may
know the fullness of a life lived where
we are all truly brothers and sisters
amen
I hope everyone has enjoyed this
morning's program it's been a wonderful
event which I'm sure will remain in all
our hearts for a long time
thank you all for coming and we hope to
see you again next year this concludes
our 30th annual Martin Luther King jr.
celebration have a wonderful day
[Applause]